let's start with this I fully fully  100,000% with no hedge do not believe  that you can teach entrepreneurship  right so that's awkward you know it's  crazy for me that that word is now  considered like cool and good I think of  entrepreneurship in a very rugged very  raw much dirtier way twenty years ago  entrepreneur meant that you were a  [ __ ] loser that was figuring it out  watching what's happening to the world  right now where this has become a hot  topic is interesting to me and like I'm  super-pumped I grew up a DNF student and  the reason I grew up a DNF student was I  was unable to sit in a room like this  and listen to whoever was sitting up  here because all I wanted to do was sell  [ __ ] I've had no other gear somewhere  around fourth grade when I got an F on a  science test I literally like that day  was like yeah that makes sense to me  because I don't give a [ __ ] about Saturn  that's not who I am